my name is Chris Randall I'm the
features editor at shorts magazine and
this is Josh O'Connor who you should
recognize I wanted to start by just
saying thank you so much for everyone
for coming in the first place and
supporting the film what people will
might notice in a minute josh is that
you don't have a Yorkshire accent in
real life so tell us a bit about where
you're actually from where you grew up
in your background yeah so I grew up in
a lovely spa town called Cheltenham
chant and Spa in Gloucestershire
and yeah but my mum was from Yorkshire
actually from North Yorkshire so she's
now an accent and I heard that your
accent was so convincing in the audition
that Frances Lee the director actually
thought you've worked this poor farm boy
that had come to audition can you tell
me a bit about yeah he um Frances sorry
I was away filming in Corfu and I sent
in a tape of me doing a couple of scenes
from the script and Frances watched it
was to say this story say the myth
Frances watched it and was I was like oh
my god we found an actor from the area
and he was like the only the only issue
is that um he looks like he's really
troubled so maybe he'd be like really
difficult to work and then obviously I
came in he I smiled a bit yeah good you
actually went up to the to farm for a
few weeks though to prepare I read that
you got into the mindset of a farmer
total method acting tell me a bit about
yeah so we is something we kind of
discussed again very early on about how
do we make this very authentic and
truthful and kind of actually the way
Francis writes is that it's very it's
very descriptive and and you feel like
you're living in that world as you're
reading it and so
yeah I didn't feel it's weird I kind of
didn't there was no real question about
it it was always going to be let's make
this as authentic as possible and
luckily that was how I'd like to work
anyway so kind of from day one the
preparation and the research into that
role was kind of almost crazily
obsessive detail and then working on the
farm yeah I worked on the farm for two
weeks with John the farmer who owns the
farm we shot on and then Alec worked on
Frances dad's farm which is a smaller
operation but is a farm so we an Alec
and I kept separate I think I told you
about yeah yeah so an hour Alec and I
kept separate for the first few weeks so
the first time we meet on screen is the
first time we actually am kind of first
time we met yeah and you were actually
like mucking out the pigs in like
driving the tractors and doing all the
real stuff that farmers presume yeah we
didn't have any pigs unfortunately we
yeah yeah
although the cow interrogation the
interrogator don't you call the
investigator that was that that shot was
the first time I'd ever done that but
you've done that to a cow right okay I
just sounded so much worse they look
really good emphasis on like first I'm
gonna cow just a clarification it's good
to know yeah that was the first time
you've done that particular examination
yeah ever and how did it go yeah that's
fine I mean it looks we got away was it
I think we did I didn't if we did any
more takes and there one thing it was
really funny because John the farmer was
because it was his farm like what was
amazing is that I'd been working on it
on that farm for like two three weeks
and so once we started filming I was
kind of so used to working on the farm
and John was so used to having an extra
set of hands that he'd sort of like I'd
be shooting a scene and then they call
cut and John would come down miss quad
be like Josh can you deliver this lamb
about and then what hands
action and then we'd be doing a scene
again so it's like proper sort of two
jobs going on and and so when we doing
the cow and see about yeah interrogation
I was going I was just about to do it
and I was kind of building up the
courage because they're huge beats yeah
and and so I was kind of getting ready
to do it and then John just before the
tapers I and I just just don't stand in
front of the back leg because he'll kick
the balls off just before they call out
this is kind of so yeah there were a few
um kind of tense moments they never work
with animals but it seems that's fine
good good and what one of the things I
wanted to ask you about this is it's
just so different to a character this is
a total transformation like how did you
find like the act of becoming Johnny
because his posture seems different and
these eyes are always down can you tell
me a bit about how you went from this to
that so as I say like I started off with
a like a scrap most carats of I kind of
almost jobs that I do I will start with
a book like a scrapbook of images that I
collect or ideas that I've jotted down
or turned out the Francis works in exact
same way so I actually learned so much
from the way France like Francis puts
like manure in there and then you get
smell or or like material that like
essentially you build up a memory bank
so that by the time you start day one of
filming ie day one of the narrative you
know Johnny sacks be in this case or
whoever it is back to front and and so
that a huge part of that obviously is
the kind of the his his axon or his the
way he stands and me in France had this
early conversation where we're talking
about like the weather in Yorkshire and
how Johnny interacts with the landscape
and I kind of I kind of what I
understood was that Johnny doesn't
interact with the landscape
it's like kind of those fields John's
farm are so beautiful for
Josh from Cheltenham because it's a
stunning landscape and it may be for
some of the audience's of this film it's
beautiful for somebody works there it's
their land it's their work and it's
muddy in its unforgiving and it's ugly
and the rain doesn't rain it's not like
normal rainfall where it falls from the
sky it falls like sideways and upside
down and it's it batters you and so you
so what you find is then you're arched
over your hoods up you don't think you
don't look up and that then also allows
for a journey for the character where
yogi comes in and teaches Johnny to take
his hood down or teaches Johnny to look
up you know they own I think it's the
only landscape shot in the film is when
they get to the to the mountainside to
the hillside and look out and that's the
first time and it's like this is
Johnny's playground this is his world
and yet he hasn't looked up he hasn't
taken it in or if he has it's it's been
that shared he's plain over yeah it's
kind of the moment where you realize
that rather than this film being about
how brutal and unforgiving the north is
that seems so beautiful that that's when
you realize it's actually a love letter
to the Yorkshire basically and that's
totally we see it through Yogi's eyes
for the first time incredible landscape
and suddenly after that I think the film
suddenly everything you start to notice
the beauty in all these little moments
yeah that's funny yeah you were I kind
of I just I just dropped in and what's
the last ten minutes of this and
actually I haven't watched this film all
the way through since Sundance when we
premiered it and I haven't watched any
more than about 20 minutes since either
but it's kind of funny how you like
looking back actually my relationship
with that landscape playing johnny was
equally kind of quite grim because it is
it's not it's just not pleasant when you
work in that world it's not pleasant and
I mean it always gets me when Gil gears
kind of comes into that world and teach
them how to interact emotionally to
humans but also to landscape and he's so
kind even when your characters dictating
I mean you know it's so amazing that
there's a character who sees the good in
people even someone who doesn't take any
[ __ ] like he's like yeah yeah but
and one of the things I wanted to ask
about this is when we meet your
character and he's you know his shell is
that his armors open his guards up and
he's sort of going around in a bit of a
not socializing do you think he knows
then that he needs someone to come and
rescue him do you think he is aware of
how lonely years
that's good question I kind of don't
know I don't actually I don't think so I
it's something I kind of you have to
think about is like I'm very lucky where
I've got a family where we I feel I can
talk emotionally hmm actually I don't
very much but I think I think if you've
got a family where you feel you possibly
can it makes a huge difference to Johnny
who has a family who they just they
don't talk about it yeah yeah it's not
like yeah there's no engagement there's
no he cannot articulate even if Johnny
had noticed a loneliness he wouldn't be
able to articulate it as loneliness yeah
and what can he do cuz he has to help
out on the farm like his family life
there's no working life are completely
inseparable yeah like a beginning of
this film
Johnny's pattern is waking up working on
the farm having a bacon sandwich
um you know and then getting pissed
having some casual sex if he needs it no
emotional engagement yeah going to bed
getting up and starting the farm again
you know there's no there's no
interaction there's no like the first
noise we hear is him retching right
that's like the first thing is just him
being sick in the toilet like yeah
exactly
I wanted to ask about Johnny with
regards to his sexuality because one of
the things I love about this film is
that it's not about him
figuring his sexuality out you mentioned
he has casual sex in the back of
trailers and stuff like that he seems to
know his sexuality really well which
makes the telling of this story a lot
more liberating so can you tell me a bit
about when you were doing the film what
was your take on the labels that he
might use or the journey that he's been
on to get to where he is because he
seems
very confident that he is attracted to
men that's never something he has to
grapple with yeah so I think the
sexuality thing is really an interesting
in that ie I certainly had it down it if
it sounds really unspecific but actually
that me and Francis talked quite long
and hard about what Johnny's sexuality
is and I think it's just that he again
it's a thing of like being unable to
articulate it
there's no he is a trap he needs to have
sex and it's with men and in this story
and I think there was a very early draft
where maybe there there was a female
character he maybe had an interaction
with but that was kind of gone I think
his sexual I mean again this film is not
about his sexuality as such yes but I
think what I found really interesting is
that is is more his relationship to
sexuality as opposed to his sexuality or
his relationship to sex and and that we
see someone who at the beginning of this
narrative is kind of takes and and
that's what he has and when someone says
do you wanna go for a drink and he's
like what I have no understanding of
what why you would do that it really
rejects that guy yeah it's totally but
then but then he kind of learns and I
think that's a really important thing
regardless of of the nature of our kind
of societal norms of what sexuality is I
think I think the I the concept of
learning how to engage sexually works
across bulletin boards and I think that
was what we were in France and I
discussed it it was very much on that it
was kind of like how do we explore that
you know and also like the it all starts
physically and then the emotional stuff
comes later which is kind of the
opposite when you see a lot of like love
like romance and stuff it's usually the
the heart goes first but it's kind of
the opposite and pretty sure their first
encounters like also kind of a fight
which is like really unromantic yeah I'm
trying to beat each other up basically
yeah whatever works yeah it's yeah
you're right
that's right were you surprised and I
asked this because I was were you
surprised that the film had such a happy
ending
yeah but happily surprised I mean as I'm
a sucker for it and so is Francis and I
think I actually very strongly believed
that we should have more hope in film
and in art in general and I think it's a
real crying shame that we don't an
especially in queer cinema where we very
often have themes of depression or
sadness or illness or prep or repression
yeah and this is a film where we're not
commenting on that and that we're
commenting on hope and in a time where
politically and society in society we're
struggling to eke out any sort of
remnants of hope it's quite nice I think
to see that in-between yeah I think the
age of just I was gonna say I think the
age of just showing how awful it is to
be gay
is kind of we're past that now and you
know we had Brokeback Mountain this and
there's a place for that of course
there's a 100% yeah but I think right
there's a place for this as well yeah
but I think you know there's been so
many great queer films this year and I
think because there's been more of them
each of them has less of a burden yeah
do the story and you've got a very
conservative ones with very little sex
then you've got this which is fairly
steamy how do you think that the kind of
the sex and the nudity and the seems
like a really integral part of this
story would you agree yeah a hundred
percent I don't know what you know
really yeah I it's funny cuz yeah in
more in America than anywhere else
we took this film people would say
there's like the first questions like
how did you handle didn't you like what
do you think about the sex doing this
appropriate it's like well you know I is
such an important part of the film
I mean you you're kind of entering a
story the way France is old Joshua James
Richard shot the film where Francis told
this story so you're on Johnny's
shoulder you're like here from the
beginning to the end of the film and
you're given as an audience for given
the
of being the third person in that
relationship and so to kind of I guess
like get to the what is a huge part of
other relationship ie sex to like shut a
door would be I think you'd be so
distant and feels so it unengaged it's
also an amazing tool for showing where
Johnny is yeah like the first time he
kisses his dream sex scene as you say
the first their first sexual encounter
is like an aggressive literally in the
mud yes it's about one hygienic yeah and
it's about Johnny yeah
very animalistic as well like you know I
think that's that's I think it's very
important essentially and I can't
imagine that film without it yeah I
wouldn't want to do from without the
other thing yeah it's really one of the
things as I say there's been so many
films where that needs to appeal to
broader audiences as meant that you know
you just don't see as much of the gay
experience in them which seems like a
bit of a comprehend what about like why
do you think then because this is I kind
of took from this and some of your
answers earlier about this one man's
journey is it's really a story about
someone finding themselves and kind of
um why do you think it's resonated with
so many people because I I know a lot of
my straight friends find this completely
mesmerizing and so what is it that you
think is partly appeal so many people I
think that well people love to see
people have to see transformation so
people like to see all the beginnings of
a transformation so people like to see
someone who is closed off or is unable
to engage with the world and see them
begin to see the light or begin to see
change people love to see happy endings
as much we might not admit admit it or
think it's very cool people need to have
more happy ending but I think also it's
just you know like for me the best kind
of reaction I got from this film was
John the farmer who I spent so much time
with and is kind of very closed off
going so
and he came he came down to London for a
screening we did for a cast and crew
screening as first time you've been to
luck first time we had a day off
actually in something like 25 years and
first time only been to London in
40-something years he came down to
London and he saw the film and he came
out and the what he said was John the
father John came out and I caught him
crying and then he said to me I was like
John what do you think yes alright but I
think that's that kind of covers all
every response yeah it's just I don't it
doesn't matter what walk of life you're
from and we're like are they from
Cheltenham spa P flea like you will I
think you'll see a film like this and
you can't help but come away with a
feeling of hope and love
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]